أشعر أن الذهاب إلى هناك هو ثاني أفضل شيء،
تعال مع الصف الأول
إلى المكسيك، هنا نلتقط صورًا لجوازات السفر، سأقوم
بتغليف بعض
بطاقات الصعود إلى الطائرة، نظمت معلمة تكساس سونيا وايت
رحلة وهمية إلى المكسيك
لطلابها، سأذهب  لتحويل
الفصل الدراسي الخاص بي إلى
طائرة، طار طلاب الصف الأول في
مدرسة Trinity Leadership School بشركة Southwest
Airlines إلى أين ستذهبون إلى المكسيك مع
أمتعتهم المحمولة وحتى
وسائد الرقبة، فأنا الآن
عميل TSA، مقطع فيديو للإقلاع يضبط
الحركة التي تحول معلمهم إليها
عصير تفاح لمضيفة طيران بعد
نظرة هبوط وعرة على ما يبدو على
وجه هذا الطفل، وصلوا إلى المكسيك، وهم
يمرون بالجمارك، أنا الآن
وكيل جمارك، انتشرت الرحلة على نطاق واسع
وحصلت على تقييمات رائعة، أفضل معلمة على الإطلاق في إد
في برنامج جينيفر هدسون ملكة جمال وايت
أوضحت أنها خطرت لها الفكرة بعد أن سألت
الأطفال ما هو الشيء الذي تتمنى أن
تفعله ولكنك لم تفعله بعد،
وقال معظمهم استقلوا
رحلة واستقلوا
طائرة، والشيء التالي الذي تعرفونه هو أن شركة Southwest قامت
بدعوة الصف الأول بأكمله للقيام بجولة في
ريو  سمعت أننا ذاهبون إلى
المكسيك، صعد الأطفال على متنها وقاموا ببناء
طائرات نموذجية، وحصلوا على حديث حماسي من
طيارة قامت
بفحص بطاقة سلامة الطيران أثناء
تناول الوجبات الخفيفة، ثم فاجأوا
معلميهم ومبادئهم، وحصل كل منهم على تذكرتين مجانيتين
ذهابًا وإيابًا
إلى أي مكان يطير إليه الجنوب الغربي
بما في ذلك المكسيك.  تبرعت شركة الطيران أيضًا بمبلغ
10000 دولار للمدرسة في
عامها الثاني فقط كمعلمة، سونيا وايت
تحلق عاليًا، هل استمتعت في
المكسيك، نعم
جيموس سي إن إن نيويورك